Just Cause does your organization offer
your people a cause so just that they
would be willing to sacrifice themselves
their interests in order to advance that
cause now one of my favorite examples of
a Just Cause was written down in the
United States in the Declaration of
Independence the founding fathers of
America wrote down a reason why they
wanted to go to war and crane create
their own country all men are created
equal they said endowed with unalienable
rights amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness in
other words they presented an ideal
vision of a future state that did not
yet exist an ideal so inspiring that
they were willing to commit their honor
their fortunes in their lives in order
to advance and winning the Revolutionary
War was simply a finite victory in this
infinite game upon winning that finite
victory like winning a client now the
heavy work begins like the founding of
the company now the heavy work begins
they will never actually achieve that
ideal but they will die trying and that
is the point and we can see throughout
the history of nations when these
nations are trying to advance their
ideal state whether it's the abolition
of slavery slavery or women's suffrage
or gay rights we can see that there's a
striving towards that ideal state that
they'll never actually reach
organizations need to offer their people
a cause so just that they would be
willing to sacrifice and it has nothing
to do with the products you make or the
services you sell no one is inspired to
sacrifice going on frequent business
trips and being away from their families
so that you can make the best products
of the best possible value nobody cares
about that Steve Jobs for example had an
ideal vision of the future state a just
cause he imagined a world in which an
individual could stand up to Big Brother
they imagined the world in which an
individual could compete with a
corporation it just so happened the
personal computer was the perfect
product to help them advance their just
cause and the people who signed up to be
a part of their company and were proud
and loyal customers it wasn't just that
the cup of
Radek was better that was debatable he
was that they saw themselves as
champions for this cause that cause
became their own it's not an accident
they attracted young people and creative
people to be such zealots for their
products it's because these were the
people who liked the idea of standing up
to Big Brother that was a just cause
sacrifice doesn't necessarily mean
sacrificing your life as I said before
going on frequent business trips being
away from your family working late hours
knowing that you could probably make
more money at another job but I choose
to stay here and I choose to do those
things not because I like those things
but because they feel worth it
are you offering your people something
to feel a part of something bigger than
themselves a vision to advance that they
feel is worth the sacrifice you must
have a Just Cause to play in the
infinite game
[Music]